so
every behavior that we do we do to
reduce uncertainty we do to increase
certainty when you go down below in a
boat and your eyes are moving and
register your boat and you're either
saying oh we're standing still but your
inner ears are saying no no we're moving
and your brain cannot deal with that
conflict so I get ill the stress
resulting from uncertainty is tremendous
in our society increases brain cell
death that decreases plasticity it makes
an extreme version of yourself we do
almost everything to avoid uncertainty
and yet the irony is that that's the
only place we can go if we're ever going
to see differently and that's why
creativity seeing differently always
begins in the same way it begins with a
question
it begins with not knowing it begins
with a why it begins with the watches
and I should also say that these
assumptions are essential for your
survival every time you take a step your
brain has hundreds of assumptions that
the floor is not going to give way that
your legs aren't going to give way that
that's not a hole it's a surface right
so these assumptions keep us alive but
they can also get in the way because
what was once useful may no longer be
useful so your brain evolves to evolved
it's adapted to adapt right so a deep
question is how is it possible to ever
see differently if everything you see is
a reflex grounded in your history of
assumptions the our assumptions and the
process of vision is both our constraint
and our Savior at the same time right
because our brain evolves to take what
is meaningless and make it meaningful if
you're not if you're not sure that was a
predator it was too late right so your
brain evolved to take this meaningless
data and make meaning from it and that's
the process of creating perception and
then we hold on to those assumptions
they create a tractor states in your
brain and they become very stable so how
could we see differently it's by
engaging the process of creating
perception well the first step in that
is to
not just admit but embody the fact that
everything you do right now is grounded
in your assumption not sometimes but all
the time because if you don't accept
that then you'll never create the
possibility of seeing differently so
much of deviate if they people walk away
with anything it's knowing the process
of perception in some sense I want them
to know less at the end and they think
they know now because nothing
interesting begins with knowing it
begins with not knowing right because
the next step is to then identify your
assumptions because most of everything
that we do we don't know why we do what
we do and then the final step is to
question those assumptions okay but
questioning assumptions is incredibly
difficult because to question
assumptions to doubt what you assume to
be true already especially if that
assumption defines who you are is to do
the one thing that our brain evolved to
avoid which is uncertainty in fact
uncertainly is such a difficult
dangerous thing that evolution has
created a brain that tries to avoid it
altogether to the extent that we have
things like conformational bias well
we'll start looking for evidence to
confirm what we assume to be true
already that we would rather hold on to
assumptions that we know don't work
because that is safer and we think then
question them and step into a place that
we don't actually know even though that
other place might be a great deal better
than where we are right this actually
this all the time within politics it
exists within the concept of the
negative view of u-turns where we
ridicule politicians for changing their
mind because they got new evidence we
want them to hold on to the same past
despite the evidence which actually
shifts them touch which actually is just
some more towards towards a belief as
opposed to anything that's evidence
driven so this also then leads on to the
idea of whether or not the brain ever
does big jumps or does the only of doers
do small steps and the answer is that
brain only ever does small
I can I can only get from here to the
other side of the room by passing
through the space in between I can't
teleport myself to the other side right
similarly your brain only ever makes
small steps in its ideas so whenever
you're in a moment it can only actually
shift itself to the next most likely
possible and the next most likely
possible is determined by its
assumptions we call the space of
possibility right you can't do just
anything some things are just impossible
for you in terms of your perception or
in terms of your conception of the world
what's possible is based on your history
right so what that means is where does
that leave us with creativity which we
have this concept that you're linking to
things that are very far apart but if
the brain never does big jumps what is
what's really happening and the idea is
that for the person being creative all
they're doing is making a small step to
the next most likely possibility based
on their assumptions but one someone on
the outside sees them doing that
thinking wow how did they put those two
things that are far apart together and
the reason why it seems that way is
because for the observer they are far
apart they have a different space of
possibility and in their space
possibility they exist way over here so
creativity in this sense is only created
from the outside not from the inside for
the person being creative they're making
a logical next step the difference is
that their space of possibility is
different they have different
assumptions different biases in fact
they might have a more complex space of
possibility because they have more
complex biases and assumptions maybe
they had a more open attitude to when
they experience other cultures etc and
they assimilated more complex
assumptions so they have more directions
in which they can move within their
space of possibility so we interpret
that is then being created by linking
things that are far apart but in fact
it's a logical process of making small
steps changing your space of possibility
by identifying and then questioning your
assumptions
[Music]